en fait ce qui est nouveau c'est qu'il
ya énormément de défunts d'il ya deux
jeunes femmes qui ont déposé plainte en
avril 2021 et elles ont été auditionnés
là elle donne des des commandes et à des
témoignages et glaçant franchement
presse people on a on a rarement vu des
choses aussi scabreuse racontée par
rapport à une personnalité donc en fait
il y en a une des deux qui qui déjà
avait été dans l'histoire puisque en
2015 jean luc lahaye avait été condamné
pour des pour des faits mais enfin
condamné à un an de sursis parce qu'il
avait dit à l'époque qu'il avait n'avait
pas eu de relation sexuelle avec cette
jeune femme sauf que là avec l'autre
personnel ont décidé de porter plainte
hélas la suite de leurs plaintes elles
ont été auditionnées et là on découvre
des trucs mais quoi baky a eu des
rapports sexuels avec des légumes avec
des objets qui a eu des pétroles des
pénétrations digitales
force et que leur maman était au courant
que certes que des mamans ont même filmé
des scènes qu'elles ont perdu leur
virginité à 14 ans que que voilà la
fille de jean luc lahaye aurait même des
pressions sur l'une d'elles pour que
pour que lors de la sphère de 2015 elles
disent certaines choses à la police
alors ça on va pas le ccc la voilà la
version des plaignants voient là on aura
l'autre version voilà et on a aussi la
réaction de l'avocat d'un des victimes
vous lira dans un instant alors épuisé
sur tout ce qu'on apprend c'est que jean
luc lahaye c'est là où c'est c'est quand
même lourd à jean luc lahaye ne nie pas
du tout avoir eu des relations sexuelles
avec ces jeunes filles n'est pas ils
n'ont pas du tout les faits en fait à
non non il il n'y pas et lui explique
que c'est qui sommes-nous pour pour
poids là pour juger ça la morale
appartient à les différences en fonction
des personnes il prend même l'exemple de
du couple présidentiel pour débat vous
voyez lui il était bien avec sa prof sa
professeur de théâtre et français pour
justifier que voilà il couche avec des
jeunes femmes qui sont mineurs sauf que
dans l'histoire les rapports sont hyper
brutaux
il y en a même une qui dit j'ai une fois
j'ai failli j'ai failli et j'ai cru que
j'allais mourir est là aussi
il ya une analyse médicale qui prouve
qu'elle a eu des contusions de
irréversible à certains endroits enfin
c'est plus glauque tumeur mais je sais
que je joue en ce moment je viens
beaucoup pour des histoires comme ça
mais alors là juste là c'est pire que
vous ayez entendu franchement là c'est
le pioneer yamal en a besoin de céréales
on a vu person façon personnelle mais
oui à la version d'un homme et ça les
regarde le truc qu'on retient et sur
lequel on aimerait revenir parce que
c'est vrai qu'on a entendu un truc qui
est quand même un fou c'est que vous
dites que les mouvements les mamans de
ces jeunes filles étaient huit complices
alors les alors que ça veut dire parce
qu'elle était alors elle était fan
la première plaignante raconte qu'une
fois elle a une relation sexuelle avec
jean luc lahaye dans un hôtel et que la
mère était dans la chambre juste à côté
qu'elle entendait tout et la deuxième
raconte que sa mère à la demande de jean
luc lahaye film et même leurs ébats
puisque l accepter que sa fille et des
ébats chez elle
avec jean luc lahaye et qu'elle a filmé
ses ébats et elle raconte même que sa
mère a eu elle-même une relation
sexuelle
avec jean luc lahaye est d'ailleurs
jean-luc lahaye justifie ça en disant
voilà elle était en colère c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui elle se venge waouh c'est
assez non alors il ya un autre dossier
sa fille qui a des problèmes de santé en
plus inquiet pas rater exactement la
fille de deux jours lui que
c'est faux parce qu'on entend tout on
entend limiter eux aussi qu'elle était
un
exemple ici qu'aux logique de son père
c'est ça c'est grave parce que bon
évidemment elle ni elle dit que si elle
a fait pression sur l'une des jeunes
femmes qu'elle a d'ailleurs même
rencontré au bois de boulogne alors déjà
la symbolique voilà
c'est à la demande de son père que elle
ne savait pas le type de relation
sexuelle qui avait son père et elle
raconte que elle même a été victime de
violences de la part de son père et
c'est enfin voila c'est assez c'est
assez dur à entendre qu'est ce que le
héros qu'est ce qu'un donc celle qui
veut empêcher mais qu'est-ce-qui qu'est
ce qui est dit aujourd'hui jean-luc
lahaye pour sa défense ah ben on lui dit
que ces jeunes familles les ai jamais vu
pleurer donc voilà de quoi elles se
plaignent qu'elles avaient l'air plutôt
amoureuse de lui que c'était pas de
l'emprise psychologique
que le fait qu'elle soit mineure bah en
même temps elle était mineur certes mais
bon il est accepté d'avoir des relations
sexuelles
il parle du c'est qu'il parle du fait
que les parents par les mamans en tout
cas été a été arrêté a été présenté
voilà étaient présentes il le fallait il
le dit hein et puis dit que voilà c'est
juste parce que maintenant aujourd'hui
elles veulent de l'argent qu'elles sont
jalouses sarr de la relation qu'il a
avec avec sa compagne bon voila il est
par contre il s'exprime pas sur les dix
sept coups de cravache qu'il a donnée à
une des jeunes filles pour ses 17 ans il
n'explique rien et du foie voilà les
légumes les sextoys et cetera pour lui
rien de choquant ce sont des pratiques
normales et que et que voilà la morale
alors on va on va lire et un entretien
entre la police et les inspecteurs pour
vous c'est normal d'avoir des relations
sexuelles avec une mineur de plus de 15
ans je vous réponds pas par une formule
de léo ferré ce qui est ennuyeux avec la
moralité c'est que c'est toujours celle
des autres ce que vous nous avez
expliqué tout à l'heure donc pour lui en
fait j rien il y juste les grosses
entente et qu'elles n'ont pas eu de mal
voila voila et puisqu'elle fait bas
qu'elles puissent être sous une emprise
psychologique du ballon elle était voilà
libres de leur choix et que sachant qu
on avait quand même une fin elles et
elles étaient toutes les deux dans à ce
moment des faits dans des des
perspectives psychologique particulière
l'une d'elles se dit harcelé à l'école
l'autre était en mal être enfin voilà
ces comportements alimentaires soit là
voilà c'est ça donc ce n'était pas des
jeunes filles qui étaient forcément
extrêmement bien dans leur peau alors
j'appelle point d'ailleurs que au moment
des déclarations de la jeune fille les
enquêteurs ont eu besoin de les
soumettre à des expertises
psychologiques pour voir si elle était
vraiment maîtresses de leur déclaration
moi j'ai le point de vue de jean luc
lahaye fin de son entourage qu'il
viendrait c'est bien d'avoir bien voilà
donc il faut déjà savoir que son avocat
dénonce un dossier à charge depuis le
début que lui parle de relation
consentie et ses avocats étaient assez
sûrs d'eux ils ont déposé une demande de
remise en liberté d'accord il est
incarcéré il est incarcéré à l'intention
de la mystique de vous dire tout ça pour
il est extrêmement choquée il nie et son
entourage se dit abasourdi par les
déclarations cet été il était encore en
très bonnes relations avec sa fille donc
je prends pas partir mais ça fait
aujourd'hui sa fille elle a la charge et
avoir la charge et son père sa chorale a
dit quoi sur son père raphaël a dit que
l avait été incitée menace est obligé de
faire brûler son sur une des plaignantes
y compris pour éviter la violence
paternelle donc ça va très très loin il
faut savoir que c'est quelqu'un qui les
difficultés de santé donc qui et qui a
été entendu à l'hôtel dieu à l'hôpital
et les enquêteurs sont très attention à
elle elle et elle est
libre elle maintenant
il en examen retour à la maison les
amendes à laver son état de santé citées
oui en tout cas elle est entendue dans
la sphère comme témoin à charge alors
oui guillaume soit on prend par bruno
quelques bribes enquête une partie tout
au moins de ces deux articles souvent
les personnes qui sont accusées de
violer le prennent les accusations très
au sérieux elle les condamne la ce qui
gêne on sait qu'on a l'impression qu'ils
ne comprend pas ce qu'on lui reproche et
il n'y absolument rien néanmoins ils
savaient que ces conversations était
problématique puisqu'il utiliser une
messagerie sécurisée pour correspondre à
ces mineurs et un vieux téléphone
blackberry qui sont des téléphones qui
sont plus trop utilisé contrairement aux
smartphones actuels parce qu'il ne
voulait pas que ces conversations soit
découvert donc on peut pas dire qu'ils
ne savaient pas ce qu'on lui reprochait
qui ne comprenaient pas ce qu'on lui
reprocher puisqu'il savait que c'était
problématique et surtout sur le
blackberry ce qui est assez horrible
c'est que c'est un ami d'enfance qui
essai par l'intermédiaire d'un ami
d'enfance qu'il l'aurait donné à la
jeune femme sachant que cet ami
d'enfance travail quand même à la dass
qui est là pour protéger des enfants
donc c'est vraiment ça vraiment cette
histoire plus glauque tu marseille
dauphin de l'honneur c'est un enfant de
la dass d'ailleurs jean-luc lahaye a dû
qui a dû
[Musique]
écouter pour les informations
cyril que j'ai d'abord s'il faut savoir
pour remettre dans le cadre que c'est
géré par la direction centrale de la
police judiciaire enquête en interne où
il ya une vingtaine d'enquêteurs qui
travaillent sur ces dossiers je vais
faire une généralité sur ce sujet là
parce que c'est important compte tenu
des faits et de ce qui se passe
actuellement vous savez qu'à 160 me de
gosses qui sont amusés on l'a vu la
dernière fois qu'on assume btp avec 15 0
c'est ces problématiques de viol et
autres c'est catastrophique ça concerne
quelqu'un de très connu donc la dcpj
s'est saisi du dossier il ya une
vingtaine d'enquêteurs qui géra écoutez
bien 300 gros dossiers d'accord sont
déjà offerts à ces barrières parmi eux
évidemment jamais fait partie les
qualifications qui ont été retenues pour
lui sur son terrible évidemment un viol
agression sexuelle enfin bref corruption
sur mineure et centre il il a la totale
diffusée il a récidivé puisqu'un 2015 il
a été quand même il a pris le nom avec
avec sursis donc abandonné les faits
sont corroborées et j'entendais
villaverde ce qu'ils lisent
effectivement que ses avocats vont
défendre ils sont là pour ça c'est
normal c'est le job je pense qu'il va
voir quand même quelques soucis pour
s'en sortir parce qu'il ya quand même
heure quand on déroule l'histoire
blokhin
se pose des questions et je pense très
sincèrement mais ça c'est un avis tout à
fait personnel que comptes-tu notoriété
etc et compte tenu des faits graves on
touche à des ensembles commencer les
mineurs il faut qu'on soit sanctionné
très durs envers nationale est tout à
fait personnel
on va papa fall protéines non mais c'est
juste une fonction d'innocence n'est
jamais d'accord mais au moment des faits
la majorité sexuelle était encore à 16
ans je crois et que de toute façon quoi
qu'il arrive il a eu des rapports
sexuels avec déjà tic ont 14 ans qui
attendait les deux dernières saisons
passées des mineurs on voit là il faut
quand même respecter la la présence faut
bien sûr bien sûr voilà bruno
aujourd'hui que va-t-il se passer pour
jean luc lahaye là il est incarcéré
depuis le 5 mai écoutez il est sûrement
entendu à deux reprises par les
enquêteurs car céret ou à la santé
d'accord il est entendu par les
enquêteurs lorsqu'il décide évidemment
et puis évidemment on déroule la pelote
comme on dit en termes de travail et le
judiciaire dont on écoute les gens c'est
toute la difficulté aussi pour les
enquêteurs de ce qui risque aujourd'hui
bel 20 ans de printemps c'est clair et
net c'est comme ça c'est donc l'actuel
main les enquêteurs déroulent les
informations mais vous savez qu à vis
des réseaux internet etc
beaucoup d'informations qui arrivent et
c'est pas évident pour les enquêteurs
sur le travail est de trouver ce qui est
vrai et ce qui n'est pas vrai parce
qu'il ya peut-être des conneries qui
sont dites par certaines personnes pour
se venger ou je ne sais quoi
et oui et non mais c'est pour ça donc
c'est un travail d'un cap qui est très
très lourd et qui demande beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de temps et de
personnel pour la leur petite question à
amiens pourquoi ces jeunes filles ont
décidé de porter plainte tant d'années
après alors ça c'est quelque chose qui
reste quand même assez floue dans
l'histoire
jean luc lahaye en fait visiblement mais
il faut faut le voir aussi comme une
espèce de dents prix psychologique jean
luc lahaye entretenait en fait beaucoup
de choses avec elle enfin il leur disait
au jeu m je me vais vivre avec toi tu
faisais des cadeaux il faisait des
choses comme ça et puis le jour où tout
ça s'est arrêté
ça leur a fait prendre conscience que
bah elle s'était elle s'était peut-être
fait avoir et que et que tout ce qui
s'était passé n'était pas normal donc
c'est pour ça qu'elle se sont unis
aujourd'hui qu'elles se seraient unis
aujourd'hui pour porter pour porter
plainte contre jean luc lahaye parce que
lui parle de vengeance oui alors lui
parle de vengeance à ce qu'il dit qu'il
avait qu'il a une compagne aucune
compagnie palais depuis et depuis donc
voilà il s'est éloigné ces jeunes filles
et il dit que c'est pour cette raison
que qu'aujourd'hui voilà il ya deux
personnes et cela est une vengeance je
ne sais pas est ce que c'est quelque
chose de plus caché qui serait quelque
chose de moins d'à voix qui serait
finalement pécuniaire pour obtenir des
condamnations et amendes peut-être parce
que je suis bien dans ma vie avec paula
sa nouvelle compagne depuis cinq ans
peut-être est-ce une faute pour elle le
fait d'être heureux avec paula alors il
dit ça aussi parce que j'ai une des
plaignantes lors de la première
condamnation attendue aussi la première
plaignante avait le droit des indemnités
et qu'elle les a réclamé au parquet et
que du coup bah il s'en sert pour dire
en fait elles voulaient de l'argent elle
n'a pas eu ou en tout cas elle avait
envie de se faire un peu d'argent sur
cette histoire reste quand même effet il
a eu des relations sexuelles avec des
jeunes fans alors on est sage et leurs
actions et leurs actions exclusive de
l'avocate des deux supposées victimes
dont une clavicule et où dans un instant
mais justement fiona et gilou et un ans
me disait que pour sa défense mais il
attaque puisqu'il dit que les deux
jeunes filles était infatigable et
surtout très en demande mais moi ma
question c'est pour vous si lui et
risque 20 ans de prison que risque les
deux mamans des deux jeunes filles pour
moi c'est un complicité ça peut ça peut
ça peut ça peut coûter cher c'est entre
cinq et dix ans suivant les faits qui
sont établis avéré évidemment enquête
les enquêteurs ont déjà reçu beaucoup
d'appels de
jeune femme disant qu'elle pourrait
éventuellement être plaignante et pour
le moment ils essayent de faire la
différence entre des relations
consenties avec des jeunes majeurs et ce
qui pourrait s'apparenter aussi à des
agressions sexuelles mais c'est sûr
qu'il ya d'autres témoins qui vont se
manifester qui se sont déjà manifestés
dans l' enquête à charge éventuelle
contre jean luc lahaye quand vous
demandez comment l'affairé remontée aux
oreilles de la justice c'est le service
sécurité de facebook en fait qui a
détecté automatiquement
mais pour la première fois la première
affaire et changeant fait piquer nous a
lancé une fan de jean luc lahaye qui
était mineur qu'il a ajouté sur facebook
très vite je vais demander des photos
d'elle dénudée elle aurait envoyé des
milliers de photos pornographiques est
en fait facebook un service qui détecte
automatiquement les conversations
problématique lorsqu'il s'agit de
mineurs donc c'est directement remonter
au service de facebook qu'il a remonté à
la justice ça sert il ya eu un travail
de phares on sait également que la
cybercriminalité qui dépend de la
direction centrale d'ailleurs qui
travaillent surtout c'est problématique
internationale féroce
savoir que c'est suite à ce signalement
que la première fois jean leclerc est un
coup a été condamnée à 2 206 cc prix
qu'on a on a la chance d'avoir l'avocate
des deux supposés victime john terry qui
a réagi juste pour nous qui nous a fait
un petit bout lebel sera peut-être avec
nous d'ailleurs lundi dans l'émission
maître nathalie bicais qui est très
sympa d'ailleurs nathalie mercier elle
divulguer des éléments d'enquêté dans un
dossier de viol est une violence
supplémentaire infligé aux victimes
ironie elle comme leurs avocats n'ont
pas encore pu accéder au dossier en
application des règles du code de
procédure pénale une plainte pour
violation du secret est envisagé cantons
font elles réservent leurs déclarations
plus d'instructions voilà ce qu'est le
10 avril par erevan havane où elle va
nous parler de ça certainement peut-être
lundi ciel est avec nous aujourd'hui que
10 des avocats de jean luc lahaye à bas
le ils disent que voilà c'est un
déferlement médiatique qui est qui et
qui est jeté sur jean-luc là et que ils
attendent la suite de l' enquête pour
faire l'éclaircissement sur cette
histoire les avocats c'est de minimiser
au maximum évidemment 15 causé à charge
des styles et ils attendent beaucoup du
travail du juge d'instruction d'accord
ils savent aussi que c'est de ce que je
sais ils sont plutôt confiants alors il
exact voilà service que oui sauf que le
dossier est lourd mais ils ont été déçus
que leurs demandes de remise en liberté
soit rester et y pense il pense qu'au
fil des conversations on s'apercevra que
la version de jean luc lahaye c'est sa
relation consentie prévaudra voilà
c'était la même info que ça sera
important d'ailleurs d'avoir la leur
leurs versions mettra pas le bon moyen
succès absolu même s'il peut venir parce
que ce serait bien d'avoir aussi la lame
évidemment lorsque je précise que je les
contacte et un d'accord mardi pour être
honnête et voilà gelée que je suis en
contact avec huit sont prêtés s'exprimer
encore à cancon à cesson gloire pour
avoir sa version c'est son droit et
c'est vrai que c'est à voir parce que
pour l'instant voilà on s'est tu vois là
on n'a pas les toutes les informations
sur cette affaire mais terry qui a fait
énormément parler et il ya des éléments
qui sortent pratiquement tous les jours
un merrien oui c'est ça tous les jours
mais là je pense qu'on est arrivé au
bout du bois